الى ملف اخر حيث يواصل الرئيس الصيني
زيارته الى موسكو حيث تبدا بعد ظهر اليوم
المباحثات الرسميه في قصر الكريم برئاسه
رئيسي البلدين ويجري الزعيمان الروسي
والصيني مباحثات حول مجموعه من القضايا
العلاقات والثنائيه والاقتصاد والوضع
الدولي والازمه الاوكرانيه
وستبدا المحادثات بين الرئيسين في صيغه
مصغره ومن المقرر اي وقع الجانبان الروسي
والصيني على ما يقرب من عشر وثائق مشتركه
بما في ذلك وثيقتان رئيسيتان وهي بيان
مشترك من قبل روسيا الاتحاديه والصين حول
تعميق الشراكه والتفاعل الاستراتيجي بما
يتوائم مع الدخول في حقبه جديده فضلا عن
بيان مشترك حول خطه التنميه للمجالات
الرئيسيه للتعاون الاقتصادي لعام 2030 كما
سيجري الرئيس الصيني صباح اليوم بشكل
منفصل مباحثات مع رئيس الوزراء الروسي
ميخائيل
نوى بهذا الخبر العاجل مشاهدينا والذي
يظهر اسفل شاشتنا حيث ان الرئيس الصيني
يقول بان الزياره الى موسكو تتوافق مع
المنطق التاريخي وروسيا والصين
تتمتعان بشراكه من امام الكرملين ينضم لنا
مراسل الجزيره من ناموسكو امين نادرغامي
امين مرحبا بك معنا اذا ما المنتظر من
مباحثات اليوم على وقع هذه التصريحات التي
بدات تخرج من لقاء الزعيمين
محمد هذه التصريحات التي صدرت عن الزعيم
الصيني هي خلال لقائه برئيس الوزراء
الروسي
ميخائيل والتي انطلقت قبل نحو نصف ساعه في
مستهل اجنده عمله خلال عمل هذه الزياره في
يومها الثاني والتي ايضا ستتواصل باستقبال
رسمي هنا في قصر الكرملين للزعيم الصيني
وايضا الوفد المرافق له الوف طبعا الحكومي
لاجراء مباحثات ثنائيه بين الزعيمين بعد
ذلك ستكون هناك
مباحثات في صيغه موسعه بحضور وزيري
الخارجيه والدفاع وايضا وزيري او محافظي
البنك المركزي الصيني والروسي في هذه
المباحثات بعد طبعا المباحثات التي شهدها
قصر كريم لان امس
بين
الزعيمين والتي استمرت لاربع ساعات ونصف
وهذا في بطبيعه الحال يظهر
يعني عدد الملفات المطروحه واهميتها
بالنسبه للطرفين كانت هناك ايضا تصريحات
امس صدرت عن كل من بوتين
واكدت على عمق ومثانه العلاقات بين
البلدين على اهميه التفاعل الاستراتيجي
مستقبلا ولعل الوثائق التي سيتم التوقيع
عليها اليوم من خلال عناوين هذه الوثائق
تبرز بشكل كبير على ان هناك حقبه جديده
تؤسس ليس فقط في العلاقات الثنائيه بين
موسكو وبيجين بل في التفاعل بينهما بينهما
على الساحه الدوليه على مختلف القضايا
سونا الاقليميه او الدوليه من بينها طبعا
الملف الاوكراني الذي امس بوتين كان قد
رحب بالخطه الصينيه خطه السلام التي
طرحتها بيجين واكد على انه يتم بحث هذه
الخطب
بالتفصيل ايضا الجانب الصيني امس كان قد
اكد على انه مستعد
للعمل من اجل احلال السلام ويعني تقريب
وجهات نظر على الاقل بين الجانبين فيما
يخص الشان الاوكراني لكن يمكن القول بان
مسائل الطاقه طبعا التجاره الدوليه والامن
العالمي والغذاء هذه المحاور الاربعه هي
التي يجري التركيز عليها بشكل كبير بين
الطرفين ولعل طبعا زخم هذه الزياره وزخم
واهميه الوثائق التي سيتم التوقيع عليها
اليوم تعكس بشكل واضح رغبه الطرفين في
الذهاب والمضي قدما بهذه العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بينهم امين درغامي من موسكو
شكرا جزيلا لك